[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui bien parole de m6 mélissa à lundi
puis cette semaine j'en avais passagers
une nouvelle un peu plus légère que
d'habitude surtout pendant la crise fait
que il ya la nation kato vichy aux
territoires du nord-ouest y ont décidé
de s'affranchir de la loi sur les
indiens et d'aller de l'avant avec leur
propre système de gouvernance ça fait
quand même plusieurs années qu'ils sont
sous la loi sur les indiens qui ont été
mis dans une réserve que c'est un
système imposé doivent gérer avec les
affaires indiennes qu'on appelle aussi
les services autochtone canada et qui
doivent toujours aller de l'avant en
demandant la permission alors pu
torpiller canada alors avant de se faire
trancher pour une communauté de 700
personnes et vend environ 500 personnes
qui était exigée va voter les 153
personnes ont voté sur 653 personnes
soit 47 produits oui on veut surtout la
loi seraient arrêtés et on veut quoi
appliquez le propre système de
gouvernance qui est extraordinaire je
doive c'est quand même un riche comme
nouvelle parce que ça va nourrir le lien
envie que d'autres communautés ou de
velours en sortir de la loi sur les
indiens mais que malheureusement ce
système là on peut pas on ne peut pas
s'attendre à ce que un jour le
gouvernement enlève la loi sur les
étrangers
ce sont des transitions et font enlever
un système de gouvernance qui était
carrément oppressante survolé les
communautés que quand une survie à
reprendre les territoires à nous mettre
sous tutelle pour un nouveau site
une nouvelle réalité sociale nouvelle
réalité ici écologique et vont
transformer notre manière d'être dans
une communauté donc que ça veut dire
c'est que il va y avoir un comité
aviseur qui va prend créent des lois
créer des systèmes dans la communauté
pour pouvoir aider au bon fonctionnement
c'est une ultime fois que cette économie
le plus être à l'image même de la
communauté
mais ça veut dire méchant
et noble jusqu'à comparer la loi sur les
1 et et tu enlèves le fait que c'est une
réserve d'indiens donc maintenant des
gens qui avaient des maisons qu'ils ne
peuvent pas les vendre à moins qu'ils
vendaient à quelqu'un de la communauté
peuvent mettre un peut-être les vendent
à des gens qui ne sont pas issues du
traité qui ne sont pas donné dans la
communauté
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il va y avoir
maintenant des non autochtones qui vont
pas revenir vivre sur les réserves sans
aucune problématique est ce que ces noms
tels que notre bon à voir la loi de la
communauté qui va s'appliquer un qui
soit sont des lois traditionnelles
donc ça risque d'être assez excitant de
voir légalement politiquement qu'est-ce
qui va s'en tenir avec ces nouveaux
changements puisque depuis huit
souhaitait on a vu un éveil il alla
collectif aucun doute du fait que des
gens ignoraient qu'on avait des systèmes
politiques différents d'une nation à
l'eau et ça ça vient en plus pendant que
cette période dans cette période si dans
la communauté de 6 les chaînes en
ontario on voit justement encore une
fois des jeunes qui veulent protéger
territoire qui bloque l'accès au
territoire mais qui se font rentrer
dedans par des policiers donc c'est
vraiment les périodes troubles mais des
périodes aussi riche puisqu'il ya des
mouvements comme blind bac qui existent
et qui veut que l'allemand je crois pas
la propriété mais je dirais la
responsabilité que les premières nations
au prix sur les communautés puissent
être encore appliquée de la façon qu'on
le faisait autrefois
parce que parler de propriété c est
rentré encore dans l'idéologie
colonialiste de ce qu'est à être sur un
territoire alors comprendre et c'est
excitant je vais suivre ça je vous
invite aussi à suivre ce qui se passe à
six nations appuyé les jeunes qui
veulent justement pouvoir créer les
nouveaux systèmes politiques créer des
nouveaux nouvelle manière de faire
surtout quand on voit que cette manière
de fonctionner sous la loi sur des
invités ne pas amener mais beaucoup de
bon dans la vie des communautés
autochtones et d'ailleurs la nation
dakota shiva allait encore pour
récupérer des territoires ancestraux
clairement été enlevée grâce à la loi
sur les indiens
donc voyez le tony gouvernementales des
communautés autochtones aux cinq des
petites communautés
c'est quelque chose qui va être
extrêmement intéressant surtout
dans les codes et les thématiques où on
va voir la gestion des territoires
autochtones sous les savoirs autochtones
sous des arbres des jeunes comme quelque
chose qui va être extrêmement important
et d'abus alors je vous donne désormais
j'espère que vous y serez pas nous
envoyer des questions et j'espère que
vous allez partager cette vidéo